TIMES JUST PRINTED AN INTERVIEW
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
WE HAVE DETAIL OSTHAT SHORTLY.
WE BEGIN WITH SAD AND SHOCKING
NEWS ABOUT SENATOR JOHN McCAIN.
WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED?
>> WITH SENATOR McCAIN'S
PERMISSION I SPOKE WITH HIS
DOCTORS EARLIER TODAY AND HE
SAID THE OPERATION HE HAD
REVEALS AN AGGRESSIVE TYPE OF
BRAIN CANCER.
THAT WAS WHAT WAS CAUSING HIS
PROBLEMS THEY OPERATED ON ABOVE
HIS LEFT EYE.
THIS IS A TYPE OF PRIMARY BRAIN
CANCER.
THEY JUST FOUND OUT AFTER THE
PATHOLOGIST LOOKED UNDER THE
MICRO SCOPE SPECIFICALLY, AND
THAT IS WHAT THEY FOUND.
AS YOU POINT OUT IT'S SAD NEWS.
THIS IS AN AGGRESSIVE TYPE OF
BRAIN CANCER AND SURPRISED
EVERYBODY.
>> WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL US
ABOUT THIS?
YOU WERE GIVEN THIS INFORMATION
OR PERMISSION BY THE SENATOR OR
BY HIS FAMILY IN ORDER TO
BROADCAST THIS?
>> YES, THEY -- WITH HIS
PERMISSION, I SPOKE TO THE
DOCTORS THEY ASK THAT I TALK TO
THE DOCTORS GET THE INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED.
WE KNOW THAT ON FRIDAY MORNING
HE WENT TO THE DOCTOR'S
BASICALLY FOR A SCHEDULED ANNUAL
PHYSICAL EXAM.
HE WAS COMPLAINING A BIT OF
FATIGUE AND SAID HE'S BEEN
FEELING TIRED OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS.
HE ALSO HAD A BOUT OF DOUBLE
VISION.
BUT BECAUSE OF THOSE THINGS HIS
DOCTORS DECIDED TO ORDER A CAT
SCAN OF HIS BRAIN.
THIS IS ALL FRIDAY THIS
HAPPENED.
IT WAS THAT CAT SCAN AND AN A
SUBSEQUENT MRI SCAN OF THE VAIN
THAT REVEALED THIS ABNORMALITY.
IT WAS CONCERNING ENOUGH THAT
URGENTLY, WITHIN THE NEXT COUPLE
OF HOURS, THE DOCTORS TOOK HIM
TO THE OPERATING ROOM, THEY PER
PERFORMED THE INCISION IN THE
LEFT EYEBROW AREA, REMOVED SOME
INTONE